it is 10 52 a.m and we are eight minutes
out from heading to
utah in this beautiful leprechaun rv so
we've got the cars packed we've got the
studio
closed up
we've got the wide open road
and only glory stands between us
and the promised land we got 10 hours of
driving to do so i think we got to hit
the road it's about that time all right
let's hit it all right see you internet
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
we're here in provo utah today we're
going to be location scouting we're
going to drive up into the mountains
we're going to find some cool fields
some valleys things that look both
pretty and kind of like mordor which uh
i guess border was kind of a nice place
even though it sounded really mean yeah
who's pretty chill apparently because
we're in utah ideally we can go and we
can shoot and nobody's going to yell at
us and demand like five thousand dollars
for like
being on the property we'll see if that
works out
signs point to yes let's see
so here we are at the first location
where we're probably gonna have the
fight scene the chasing and all kind of
stuff taking place the thing that we
gotta keep in mind with the location
like this is where the best backgrounds
are and where the best frames are if you
think there's a cool background over
there there's also a cool background
over there you gotta kind of pick one um
so we're strategically trying to figure
out where we're gonna position
everything so we can get all the best
backgrounds in the shot where italian
come from if i run off into those trees
yeah i kind of assumed his like
monster dash would be coming from those
trees over there
because of the tree or what yeah
sick free bill
so you wanna have the running chasing of
them going uphill you wanna have them
running chase scene downhill
because it will have more takes if they
go downhill i mean
they need to focus on that mountain in
that valley in that valley i guess so
our friend eddie king at teddy films
uh
was uh
doing some location scouting for us and
he was actually looking for another
location
and he accidentally came to this one
um and we were like wait a minute that
one's way better and
here we are
so we are making a video board where
we're going to just roughly shoot out
some intended shots and intended angles
just to get a sense of uh where we need
people and where we need the camera to
be on the day of filming we're going to
squash b swappy
swappy i don't know
even though this field's pretty much the
best ever uh
we're just gonna check it out because
you never know
never know what's on top of squash feet
swappy swappy
so the hardest thing about location
scouting is balancing the two things
involved in a location scout one cool
looking places and also
places where you can actually hold your
chute and so we found some really cool
views we found some cool mountains
you don't even know what's behind you
right now some even cooler stuff but the
problem is that unfortunately there's no
place to actually
shoot here there's no openings there's
no fields
don't have the room to do what we need
to do so
we're just going to soak this in
and now we're going to go
are we rolling right now yeah yo what up
internet um the first day of location
scouting is sweet utah is a very pretty
place we got soaked we got caught in the
rain everything looks awesome no matter
where you go except the mountains
exactly what we expected the best views
unfortunately have a highway running
through them got a field it's sweet got
some runes it's sweet now i just gotta
plan the shot list hardest thing to do
figure out
where people are going to be
what beats and actions we need to film
and then finally what background do we
put them against bring it all together
wrap it all up with some color grading
and you have yourself a
video yes yes i have some minor league
okay we're just here to be the big guy
oh
see see that look on his face
do you like the taste of steel no
oh actually i do
all the orcs get into makeup but that's
like a
three hour process i think they got up
at 5 a.m it's like 9 30 now
uh call time was 8 30 but it's cool
i'm not going to give them crap about it
unless they watch the spanish scenes
video we already have all like the shots
planned but now it's like where are
people going to be exactly so that we
can just roll the wheels when we get
here
okay
yeah
cool damn this high altitude just
walking a to b i'm out of breath
like it still feels like i have
something large in my eye
because you do you do yeah
contact lens orcs aren't good with eye
drops proper 180 here is for him to be
activated
okay you're right now i'm just saying
you want to scoot them over 20 feet so
we have the proper background at least
yeah sure okay it's fine and guys one
more thing
uh just scoot the group right to here
with the bush in the middle
how's everything going so far there
well actually you know it's going pretty
good uh we got off to uh
a bit of a slow start but actually
things are pretty much on track now so
we have the pleasure of using a movi on
this shoot that's perfect because first
off we're in the middle of nowhere we
can't bring out a huge dolly track we
can't bring out a huge jib arm even
though we did but it's not good for
running shots and there's a lot of
running in this opening scene so
basically we've put one of our tightest
lightest lenses on here
and uh we're basically just sprinting
through the field funny enough when
you're using this camera on the movie
you can get a great shot without even
looking at the screen half the time
because when you're running at full
speed through a
bunch of dirt you don't even have time
to so spin it around and stuff
whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa
keeps me stable when i'm not able
three two one action
hey jared
jared hey
i'm sorry
not the best way to do it
could i could i get one beauty shot of
you one you're getting it right now
all right
come in a little closer to sam yeah a
little more towards me like right and
back up a little bit because it's very
bright and we just need to see that
little that little finish of light
there we go
let me see the little motion go for it
it's sweet
[Applause]
i'm one of the slaves john and uh
i put together these costumes this
is foam
like the little mats that you use we use
heat
and bend it to how we want it cut it
exacto knives
and then this is something called
warbler if you're a cosplayer you know
what this is the high end cosplay armor
they use this heat reactive so i just
cut big strips of this double thick
and then bent it
around and then these are carpet tacks
and these are little rubber things that
go on the bottom of your devices and
protect your desk
but now they're metal
what are you doing
i'm gluing his face back on
don't look at me i don't have my face on
it just comes loose after
lotion don't worry about it that kind of
stuff
sweating just right there right in the
front
just like do it every other shot more or
less you wake up like you look at your
hands as if the slave would be in them
and they start itching right away
yep we are
maybe 10 shots out from ending the day
if we get five of these shots done we
have five shots to do tomorrow that's
totally fine because all we have to do
is a fight scene in like
three shots at the end
so
a little bit of production math
leads me to believe that we're in good
shape as long as it doesn't rain a ton
tomorrow which might
and then
see you then
[Music]
wow
dude yeah nice
that was the last shot of
our drone shots today
i was really not expecting billy to go
on an all-out sprint because it looked
awesome and i wasn't expecting
aaron and chris to pull off such an
awesome shot because i
i was actually out of ideas
that's all i got
so when you run out of ideas let the
pros do what they do best
hi my name is luke lafontaine i'm
actually the short fight choreographer
for this shadow of mordor corridor
digital shoot but what i'm doing right
now is putting rubber cement on the
bottom of
italian's boots to give them grip um
barge cement is usually used to glue
leather together in leather making and
when it dries it dries with a really
tacky rubbery surface so this is gonna
work really good on the bottom of these
leather shoes so that our stunt guy
billy here has got better grip when he's
sword fighting
it's actually a pedicure
okay last thing stabbing him
like kind of like go go like uh like
what is it like shooting the rest of the
fight scene we're shooting it as fast as
we can because there's a thunderstorm
coming so it's a race against
mother nature
that's good
action
[Applause]
all right cut reset
and i am
rolling at 120 frames per second that
means i just caught like every single
frame you could have ever wanted there
so even though we're filming the real
sword chances are we're still going to
just use it as a cg sword because we
have to use it to simulate all the blood
pouring out of his opened chest
but this is great reference to you know
model the lighting and you know get the
reflections right for that speaking in
which i should get an hdr for this
thanks for reminding me
when he pulls it out
he's doing this right yep because it's
pulling his bicep he goes
you got it yeah is that what you want
yeah give me a little push though just
give me a little push so it's like a
little extra we're about to get a lot of
shade hurry up let's do it still sunny
all right
okay let's just do it right now here we
go
[Applause]
call it three two one action
cut great
so uh we have to get to the runes but to
get to the ruins we had to cross a creek
to cross the creek we have to walk
across a 2x6 so i'm going to go do that
holding this
really expensive piece of equipment
so these prosthetics that we have here
we're using on all the our orc
characters except two
they're all foam prosthetics that were
donated to us by scott ramp from scream
team he's very generous and letting us
use his prosthetics for this
video and they all look really amazing
and different
so i'm adam lyons normally i'm a dating
coach however today i'm going to be a
slave running away from a whole bunch of
orcs and goblins go figure it's like
this ideally we don't see you or notice
you until you move and it's like oh
there's a guy right there and
then all you do is hide like this okay
got it
yeah
there you go what
don't do this
bad idea
oh my god
dude
[Applause]
you